I'm Jason Chaffetz I'm Katie Pavlich I'm
Steve Ducey and this is the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
July 6th 2022 I'm Dave Anthony another
mass shooting another round of questions
on how to prevent someone who posts
about violence online from becoming
violent you see it all the time where
people are getting knocked off the
social media because of the reviews well
that same type of Technology can be used
to try to keep people from committing
acts by notifying those who have the
ability to do something about it I'm
Alex Hogan the U.S is Banning the sale
of all products sold by e-cigarette
company Jewel the reason why the vaping
products are attractive is because they
if you look at the pharmacokinetics of
some of these vaping products Jewel
included they really replicate the sort
of experience of smoking I'm Liz peek
I've got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
it's yet another place people thought
was safe but like a supermarket in
Buffalo New York or a school in Uvalde
Texas the Fourth of July parade in
Highland Park Illinois was not we heard
a few faint just send pops which
all of us believe that we're just you
know fireworks instead it was gunfire
everyone kept screaming shooter run run
run and the shots kept coming bang bang
bang and you kept hearing the shots go
off and off and off it must have lasted
about two minutes we saw people falling
people screaming everybody was running
inside and then we started noticing how
many people were bloody in the end seven
people were killed more than 30 were
wounded by a gunman dressed in women's
clothing and investigators do believe he
did this to conceal his facial tattoos
and his identity and help him during the
escape with the other people who were
fleeing the chaos the suspect captured
and arrested hours later is Robert cremo
III during the attack we believe that
kareemo fired more than 70 rounds from
this rifle into the crowd of innocent
people Chris cavelli with the Lake
County Major Crimes task force says that
gun was purchased legally and the attack
had been planned for weeks at this point
we have not developed a motive from him
they're also pouring over the 21 year
old's social media posts some reportedly
depicted or advocated violence what's
sad is you look at all the warning signs
we see in this and other cases and you
wonder why are we not doing more to try
to prevent this from happening John
yanarelli is a former FBI special agent
why are people not picking up the phone
and calling law enforcement why are
social media companies not using their
algorithms to notify law enforcement
about dangerous and nefarious postings
there's a lot that can be done of course
the responsibility starts and stops with
the actual shooter themselves they're
responsible for their actions for what
they did look we as a society can be
doing more to try to get this under
control yeah more and more we see we had
of course what happened in Buffalo New
York we had what happened in Uvalde
Texas all recent and now in this case
more details come out about his being a
rapper supposedly awake the rapper was
his name and he had videos on YouTube
that have been taken down depicting
violence supposedly like a fictional
school shooting and in another case like
a stick figure wanting to attack a crowd
with the caption I need to just do it
it's my destiny all of that are warning
signs that people who see this sort of
stuff pick up the phone call the police
and I can't emphasize enough you call
the cops it doesn't mean somebody's
getting arrested frankly there may not
have been a crime that was committed
prior to yesterday's shooting but as a
former police officer myself I've
responded to these calls where you go
out and talk to an individual and you
ask them do you feel like hurting
yourself or somebody else if they say
they do that gives law enforcement the
ability to bring them for psychiatric
evaluation let doctors have a chat with
them look at their medical profile and
maybe something can be done you know I
read something where his uncle said You
know what last time I saw him just the
other day he was on the computer
everything looked normal quiet guy but
he also said that he was lonely and and
the other thing that he said on that is
he's usually on his own he keeps
everything to himself do you think the
family even knew that he had videos on
YouTube they may not have known but he
probably had people watching and YouTube
knew he had videos on YouTube and from a
technological standpoint I used to work
in the FBI cyber division there are
algorithms out there that they can look
for acts of violence nobody has to be
sitting and watching those videos a
computer program will scan through and
look for things that can be damaging and
dangerous and then use that information
to alert authorities Dave you see it all
the time where people are getting
knocked off the social media because of
their views well that same type of
Technology can be used to try to keep
people from committing acts by notifying
those who have the ability to do
something about it the FBI receives
complaints constantly from around the
country from concerned citizens all of
them are processed and weeded out to
various law enforcement agencies in the
right jurisdiction for that department
to decide do we need to follow up do we
need to talk to this person and I will
tell you many times we decide after the
fact yes somebody should have talked to
this person not just YouTube I want to
ask you since you've been dealing with
cyber at the FBI you clearly know about
Discord apparently he was also on
Discord which I've it's an app or a at
least a website or whichever I'm not
sure which but on on it he was a
frequent poster apparently on a message
board that discussed murder and suicide
and beheadings and he posted some videos
that I I assume people would would find
alarming what do you do about that the
exact same thing now Discord is a site
where people can post all sorts of
things in you know basically it could be
attacking other people but that's that
whole world of social media where it's
the wild west and people can post
anything they want but at the same time
now you're getting people who are
identifying themselves at least
electronically if they're not using the
real name there's still a electronic
signature that the agency the FBI and
the social media company would know
where to go back to they can contact
those people and talk to them again not
necessarily a criminal activity that
somebody'd be arrested for but if you
gave me the name and said hey this
individual's posting these terrible
things I'm going to run them through the
computer system I'm going to see if
they've been arrested before I'm going
to see if they legally own weapons all
those things go into the collection of
what kind of interaction and effect that
we want to have to try to prevent this
person from doing something that could
be more damaging do you think that all
of those people should be looked at I
mean if everyone's chatting and
discussing things like this
do they need to be looked at and how
many people are we talking about well
those are great questions and I think
the other part of the question is where
do we draw the line who do you look at
and who do you not look at and I will be
honest I don't have all the answers here
but this is the conversation we need to
be having yeah and there are those who
will be a little nervous about the
government investigating all their posts
online because you know hey I I it's a
free country I can I can say what I want
absolutely you've got that First
Amendment right and you should be able
to do that and that should be defended
but at the same time your First
Amendment right doesn't extend to you
being able to say I'm going to commit
acts of violence I'm going to do this
you can say those things but there's
penalties for when you do it when you
threaten someone and when you carry it
out in the last several shootings that
have gotten a lot of attention Buffalo
an 18 year old suspect who had a lot of
hate speech and apparently targeted
black people in the supermarket in
Uvalde you have the dead gunman in the
elementary school people talked about
how he was dressing like a school
shooter in black he was carrying around
bags of like dead cats
you talked earlier about family members
what should people start doing that
they're not doing are people afraid of
turning a family member in what should
be done
I think the way Society is today a lot
of people are just afraid of having
conversations and sitting down with kids
and talking to them about what's going
on and understanding what's happening in
their life the social media makes it so
much more complex all the more reason
not just parents siblings aunts and
uncles other family members be engaged
know what's happening in young people's
lives and if you think that he's quiet
he keeps to himself make sure you know
that that person is doing okay not just
that he's quiet and suffering in silence
you want to be able to be a resource and
if you can't do it alone that's when you
find resources out there there are
mental health facilities there are
treatment a lot of times as a cop I got
called the person didn't get arrested
what they got was referrals of where
they can get treatment and the family
can get get help to help that individual
last month President Biden signed a new
law with new gun restrictions oh this
bill doesn't do everything I want it
does include actions I've long called
for that are going to save lives one
provision provides funding for States
enacting so-called red flag laws that
could keep Firearms away from those
Accord deems a danger to themselves or
others though some Republicans oppose
that fearing it could set a low bar for
taking someone's rights away there's got
to be checks and balances with that as
well now certainly if somebody is in
possession of a weapon and saying things
that lead you to believe they're going
to commit acts of violence but haven't
crossed that line yet we want to prevent
those acts of violence but at the same
time that person has the right to then
go in front of an authority a judge Etc
and show no I'm not going to do anything
wrong I am capable of being a
responsible little gun owner I want my
weapons back we want to make sure that
people in crisis are not going to hurt
anyone or themselves a lot of these
situations we see are not the terrible
homicides that happened yesterday but
suicides as well suicide is essentially
homicide turned inward so events like
that those types of red flag laws they
may be part of the solution but again
you got to have that check and balance
because we don't want people to lose
their second amendment rights and not
have them restored when there's actually
no problem at all should parents be
checking their teenagers devices
absolutely a lot of a lot of teenagers a
lot of kids are like hey get out of my
room you know well that's great you know
when my kids were young I used to check
all their devices and I would have other
parents who would ask me well don't you
trust your children and my answer was
always of course not there I love my
kids they turned out to be wonderful
young adults but I am responsible for
making sure they're raised right and
they're making good decisions and it was
up to me to make sure all those things
were taking place I would say as parents
you wouldn't let your kids go out late
at night and go somewhere unless you
knew where they were going when they
were going to be home well the
internet's late at night 24 7. you're
letting your kids get in into an
environment interacting with strangers
who are inviting them quote into their
electronic homes you want to be
proactive and know what's happening so
that you can be there for your kids to
keep them out of trouble but more
importantly to keep them safe John
yanarelli former FBI special agent thank
you very much for joining us
thank you for having me
[Music]
this is Liz peek with your Fox News
commentary coming up 480
000 people in the U.S die each year from
cigarette smoking and that includes
second-hand smoke according to the CDC
to break the habit or as an alternative
millions of Americans have turned to
e-cigarettes and one of the leading
companies now faces a major challenge
the FDA has banned the sale of all
products sold by Jewel these products
never should have been allowed to come
to Market that the American Lung
Association but the president of the
American vaping Association argues that
jewel is a healthier alternative to
cigarettes and that the company will
appeal any decision and this will allow
them to keep their products on the
market while that appeal is pending the
major question for Regulators is how to
create a safe pathway for addicted
adults while also trying to reduce the
rate of use for combustible tobacco
products meaning flammable substances
think cigarettes and cigars it's not the
nicotine itself that causes all the
death and disease from smoking it's the
combustion this is Dr Scott Gottlieb
former FDA commissioner and a senior
fellow at AEI and so if you can
transition a lot of current smokers onto
non-combustible products you could
probably have a significant public
health impact so the agency has been
trying to balance two competing
challenges one is the challenge of
trying to advance that vision of
reducing the use of combustible products
while keeping kids from getting
initiated on nicotine through those same
Alternatives and we saw after we
promulgate those policies in 2017 saw a
very dramatic rise in the rate of use of
e-cigarettes by kids driven largely by
Jewel and the concern became that you're
going to end up hooking a whole new
generation of children onto nicotine
some proportion of which are going to
migrate onto combustible products if we
don't intervene to take steps to try to
reduce the appeal of these products to
kids and so we took a series of
enforcement actions when I was at FDA
against some of the manufacturers that
we felt were positioning these products
to children while at the same time
trying to implement some regulations
that would reduce their appeal to Kids
one was the fruity flavors others dealt
with the way they were sold and marketed
Congress stepped in and raised the age
requirements for purchasing tobacco
products recognizing the problem on a
very broadly bipartisan basis now what
you're seeing in the current
Administration I think is you know a
continuation of some of those efforts as
well as you know the administration
extending some of those measures they
have cleared some of the vaping products
to remain on the market and more
recently they made a decision to pull
Jewel off the market because of very
specific problems that they found
associated with that particular product
not necessarily the legacy of Youth
abuse of that product it was specific
manufacturing problems for example they
felt that it was a manufactured in a way
that it allowed the leaking of the um
The Vaping liquid where it could become
superheated and potentially have some
harmful effects
the FDA said in this that it doesn't see
clinical information that suggests that
there is an immediate risk to using
Joule products so does that mean that
the agency thinks that the information
provided just isn't factual or that the
information provided isn't
straightforward enough to alert the
public about the possible side effects
and addiction
it's probably the latter that the
information was incomplete they didn't
cite any evidence as you noted saying
that the product itself had risks in
excess of what the other products had
associated with them after all these
aren't you know entirely Safe products
there are harms Associated anytime
you're going to be inhaling something
like that into your lungs so what they
said with the jewel product was that
there were certain problems associated
with that device and this leaking that I
mentioned and that the applicant didn't
provide sufficient uh evidence to sort
of quell the agency's concerns and so it
could be an issue where the company
could resubmit more data and potentially
get an approval if you read the
application the denial that FDA issued
it does seem to leave the door open to
the possibility that they could file
more information with the agency now
that said that would take a while the
company's working on a Next Generation
product that provides bluetooth
tethering to the phone where you can you
know fully age restrict these products
in fact most of the companies are doing
that and I think by the time they would
probably refile do the studies that the
FDA might require and refile they'll
probably be more focused on that next
Generation product assuming they can
continue as a going concern the interim
exactly you some users of Jewel are
really against this move saying that
this basically is is taking away a step
that they use to walk away from
cigarettes so that's their perspective
and do you think that this motion this
move could lead to more of an emphasis
on Alternatives right now like gum or
patches
you know potentially I think that one of
the things that I wish that we Advanced
further when I was at the agency which
we pushed on but it was challenging to
get the drug Center to change some of
its historical approach to these
products was the medicinal nicotine
products you know one of the things that
makes a nicotine replacement product
that sold as an over-the-counter drug
attractive to smokers is the speed of
the delivery of the nicotine the reason
why cigarettes are so addictive isn't
just the high amount of nicotine in them
because after all you can get a gum or a
patch or a lozenge that has a high
amount of nicotine in it it's the speed
of the delivery of the nicotine to the
brain that's that's what gives it some
of its addictive qualities and so if you
can come up with medicinal nicotine
products that can offer nicotine in a
sort of formulation that allows more
rapid delivery into the blood that could
be a potentially more attractive product
to an adult smoker who's looking to quit
combustible tobacco and wants an
alternative so I think that there's a
lot of opportunity if that the reason
why the vaping products are attractive
is because they if you look at the
pharmacokinetics of some of these vaping
products Jewel included they really
replicate the sort of experience of
smoking in terms of the speed of
delivery of nicotine and so for a smoker
you can replicate a lot of the appeal
that you get from smoking in terms of
using a combustible cigarette as a
nicotine delivery device through a
vaping product and so I think that
there's a real opportunity to continue
to refine these products and use them as
an alternative smoking
yeah and especially since we're talking
about these products and the goal of it
being child proof as of last year one
out of every nine high schoolers says
that they've used one of these products
in the last 30 days and one out of every
35 middle schoolers so this is a huge
number in society so do you think that
this is comparable to cigarette usage in
the teens back in the 60s and the 70s
before cigarettes were really marketed
as being unhealthy and unsafe look we've
seen overall tobacco use come down among
children and that's the good thing and
we've seen the use of combustible
tobacco come down although we have seen
things like dipping go up and cigar use
among kids if you look at the trends in
recent years there's no question and
this was always the criticism of the
policies aimed to try and occur team use
of the E-Cigarettes that some proportion
of kids who might have chosen to smoke
are now using e-cigarettes instead I
think that that's a relatively small
proportion quite frankly I think it's
more likely the case that kids never
would have chosen to use nicotine at all
are now being initiated on e-cigarettes
I think that's a higher proportion of
what we're seeing among children and the
concern is twofold number one you know
nicotine is not a completely benign
substance even though it's not what
causes all the death and disease from
smoking number two inhaling anything
into your lungs is not healthful there's
going to be some deleterious effect of
that over time so you don't want to use
the lung as a drug delivery platform and
the other the third concern is that some
proportion of those kids who are getting
initiated on nicotine through
E-cigarettes are going to migrate onto
combustible tobacco we know that the
data shows that you know it could be
cheaper to smoke and that's why kids
choose to do it and that's the third
reason why you don't want to see this
big complement of children starting to
use e-cigarettes
it's basically just Paving the way for
the next generation of smokers and and
in trying to combat that and trying to
bring down the level of people numbers
of people who do smoke in the U.S what
do you think about the marketing and
what that does over the course of
decades taking a look at the UK where I
am in the 1970s smoking rates were about
50 percent and as of 2020 only 13
percent of the country smokes and a lot
of that is attributed to marketing
specifically the law here that companies
have to include very graphic photos of
rotting teeth and throat cancer and
tumors on their products and there was
the potential of that kind of law being
passed in the U.S but it was struck down
so right now there are warnings on
cigarette packs and other products do
you personally think that more imagery
like that would make a difference for
not only adults but also kids that are
potentially using these substances
yeah I mean that that may still go
forward it was held up it's held up into
courts on First Amendment grounds but FJ
was given the opportunity to sort of
reformulate the graphic warnings that
would be required on the cigarette
packages and I think that that's still
uh moving its way through the regulatory
process it was challenged on First
Amendment grounds and whether or not the
commercial speech was protective speech
and could companies be compelled to have
to speak in a certain way so we'll see
where that ends up I think that the data
on the graphic warnings was in some
respects uh mix there was some evidence
that showed that it did have an impact
on people and did make people more
conscious of the unhealthy effects of
using combustible tobacco products and
other kinds of tobacco products like dip
but maybe that the impact of those kinds
of ads wasn't as significant as we
perceived and in terms of where you're
gonna make your regulatory push and try
to advance policies you might not be
getting the most bang for your buck with
those kinds of approaches but I think
that by by and large what you've seen
Public Health authorities pursue you
know including the FDA when I was
running the agency was in all of the
above approach if there was something
that you could do that could make people
more aware of the unhealthful effects of
tobacco use
um while not curtailing or significantly
hampering opportunities for current
adult smokers to transition either off
of cigarettes or onto things that were
less harmful you wanted to pursue those
well another effort that the FDA is
pursuing to limit smoking in the U.S is
the plan to cut down nicotine levels so
New Zealand right now is the only
country that has moved forward with this
kind of goal do you think that this is
feasible in the U.S do you think that
the country is is ready and is moving in
the direction of more regulation and
support for that when it comes to these
products I think it's feasible in the
U.S I think it's a long time Horizon to
implementing it um and we always knew
that you know this was first proposed in
2017 it was supported by the Trump
administration at the time but we always
knew it was going to take a long time to
transition to it uh framework where you
can start to reduce the nicotine levels
in the combustible products so that the
combustible products can no longer
sustain addiction you know first of all
you needed to give the industry time to
retool this wasn't something that they
could do overnight you also needed to
get the framework in place that would
allow products on the market that would
offer an alternative to currently
addicted of those smokers you couldn't
just say you know we're taking all the
combustible nicotine Products off the
market and this isn't going to be
available anymore I'm nicotine after all
is a legal substance there's adults who
want to enjoy it there's adults who are
addicted to it so we needed to provide
those Alternatives and and that's what
you've seen I think the agency try to do
the idea is to make the combustible
products less attractive and then open
up a pathway for the non-combustion
products and so hopefully over time
you'll migrate more smokers down the
Continuum of risk onto the
non-combustible products and hopefully
have a health impact at the same time
Dr Scott Gottlieb former FDA
commissioner and a senior fellow at AEI
thank you so much for joining us thanks
a lot
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from Fox News listen and
download the Fox News hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com raid
and review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your Fox News commentary Liz
peep
what's on your mind Americans are
Furious despondent and fed up with Joe
Biden the country has gone off the rails
and the president seems utterly
incapable of fixing what's wrong
the president is causing a series of
Firsts including worst presidential
approval ratings ever worst consumer
sentiment worst bond market in modern
times and worst ever small business
pessimism about the future the economy
is slumping High Energy prices are
raising the cost of everything and air
travel is a disaster
let's start with the economy even as
Biden idiotically continues to tout the
accomplishments of his economic agenda
our country is sliding into recession
when consumer sentiment hits its worst
level ever recorded as the University of
Michigan reported occurred in June it
impacts spending which sure enough
slowed significantly in May consumer
incomes are not keeping Pace with Rising
prices as they exhaust their savings
they will retrenched further in the
months ahead consequently the job market
which has been Rock Solid is beginning
to fray the four-week average of new
jobless claims is rising and is now at
the highest level since December in the
tech sector companies that had been on a
multi-year hiring speed like meta have
suddenly switched gears and announced
layoffs big retailers like Target or Bed
Bath and Beyond that reported
disappointing sales and Rising
inventories will inevitably trim workers
as they struggle to rein in higher costs
it isn't just the economy that's heading
south
over one of the busiest travel weekends
of the Year Airlines crushed holiday
plans for many Americans by canceling
thousands of flights Travelers whose
flights were canceled could have driven
to their destinations instead those
unlucky Souls would have been confronted
near five dollar per gallon gasoline
prices which their president and his
advisors have said was the cost of
preserving the quote World liberal order
at home Biden has resolutely refused to
meet with oil industry Executives in
order to craft a mutual response to
sky-high oil prices it is a petty
gesture of hostility towards one of
America's most consequential Industries
Biden says he is doing everything
possible the lower gasoline prices but
that is not true not only has he
restricted short-term U.S oil and gas
production he is moving to reduce output
in the years to come as well meanwhile
young people in the United States just
starting out to build their families and
careers are finding that buying a house
is more expensive than it has been since
2006. Rising mortgage rates combined
with high house prices have led more
Americans to rent pushing rent 17
percent higher across the country
according to a recent poll 85 percent of
Americans think our country is headed in
the wrong direction and that's with a
robust job market yes things could get
worse
this is Liz peek Fox News contributor
listening to the Fox News rundown
rundown stay up to date
to driving to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
hi everybody it's Brian Kilmeade I want
you to join me weekdays at 9 A.M East as
we break down the biggest stories of the
day with some of the biggest newsmakers
and of course what do you think listen
live or get the podcast now at
briankillmedshow.com
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes